how many old machines do you have out of
interest I don't know
however few vac stations over large
effects which was from a friend I have
another pdp-11 which is much smaller
than this one it's designed for
controlling a robot arm in a Nokia plant
I think PDP Levin's are particularly
interesting because it was the machine
that UNIX was developed on and then
probably also see after that you know
they were building C on top of Unix
so it's quite a historical machine I
think this
1173 and a 23 plus Jessie I think it
runs at about 14 megahertz it has one
megabyte of RAM it's using this scuzzy
to SD adapter some point I have to get
my 10 megabyte orally to drives which
are about this sort of size but twice
twice the height they're not working at
the moment ok hard disks yeah they're
removable platter disks so each platter
has ten megabytes and you can switch the
platters between each Drive it's kind of
a mixture of two machines I mean it has
ran from bomb and a CPU from another but
probably around 1983 so it's one of the
later pdp-11
it doesn't have the toggle switches on
the front for example so we can actually
pull these cards out I'm gonna
disconnect it from from the mains I
think it should be fine anyway but I
will spin it around I'll just remove
these ribbon cables and then yes it will
start from the bottom and then actually
discuss them from the top that's
terrifying things it looks pretty
straightforward though the system of
connections and everything yeah so
actually what's going on in the back
here is just it's just a bus there's
just cards connected together in fact
you have to have a card in every slot if
you want to use the slot below it
traditionally these would have been wire
up I think on this machine it's it's
soldered so this is kind of
mass-production pdp-11
as opposed to to handmade so this is the
PDP 1173 processor one of these I think
is floating-point any other one is just
just general arithmetic and you know
standard move memory kind of
instructions most of the object down
here it's just for communication with
the bus you know getting the voltage
levels right and things like that this
one has two serial ports and some status
lights it's called a multifunction board
so it actually has 128 kilobytes of RAM
separate from those it has these boot
ROM so you you don't have to type in
assembly programs basically to to boot
from your disk
and it also has sometimes a some kind of
real-time clock as well which is useful
keeping time this is the first memory
port it's half a megabyte and there's
another one of those so one of the
interesting things about these machines
is the every device has been allocated a
part of memory and you actually
configure the the memory address of
these boards by wire wrapping basically
binary numbers onto the jumpers in my
early memories of PCs Lucy's dip switch
is that kind of the same sort of thing
it's a bit like that but you end up
wanting to connect a lot of jumpers to
different ones and every board is
different so if you don't have the
manual you can they basically never get
them working but a lot of the manuals
for these machines have been archived
actually which is great so the starting
address of this is is zero if it hasn't
it has a hundred twenty eight kilobytes
of memory on it so it starts at zero
this one then starts at 128 this is a
clever board it it does actually have
dip switches this pdp-11
is a complete Frankenstein of a machine
so when we go to the sense of computing
history and talk to Jason about some of
the old machines it seems to be the case
that they all are I mean these were
functional things that were used weren't
that yeah so just I mean I bought this
card separately off eBay it wasn't that
GV with it unfortunately but with
without I don't have a working disk
which I could boot up well I'm working
disks for scuzzy but I also have you
know an or a to controller and a tape
controller but I don't have these
devices to actually the machine from so
this one communicates whether this so I
could plug a normal debt because he
drive into this by deck aiming Digital
Equipment Corporation the peeps of
people who make this a machine or made
it they was hauled to Compaq actually we
can type in some basic programs in
assembly well actually there's actually
an octal and then once we get bored of
doing that because it's a lot of work we
can boot into Unix
and maybe play some games and show you
roughly how similar it is now to two
modern Linux and UNIX so I don't want to
get those two cards build up shouldn't
we have static wrist strap
probably the nice thing about these
machines is you can usually fix them
when you kill them so it hit hard but
that's that's actually part of the fun
of it and if you just have it boot from
UNIX I mean I can send email and where's
the keyboard and all that sort of stuff
the keyboard is all the way over there
so this is actually kind of similar to
what you would have in a company you
would have maybe 16 or so terminals
hooked up to a single pdp-11 and you
would access them remotely because it
was too expensive to put the hardware
next to the terminal so everyone would
share a single machine which is it's
kind of coming back now with cloud
computing and things so it's clearly a
good model so that's my virtual halls at
23 driver that's pretending to be the
hard disk with you it's actually
designed for Amiga how that backed up
[Music]
I will reset it because I want it to be
in a mode that we can type there's a
reset switch and that's just for you
know basically hard resetting machine it
goes back to to a starting point there's
this halt one which actually suspends
the machine and at this point you can
use the ODT which is the online
debugging tool to insert memory adjust
memory look at memory look at the
register state and that's actually what
we'll be typing in a program in to do
something very simple in a moment and
then the last one is is this auxiliary
input which I don't really know what it
does if I don't have it enabled it won't
boot UNIX I think it's sometimes some
kind of clock that UNIX and other
operating systems require or keeping
time of things so I plug up the serial
back in this would typically go on the
back it's actually look at the wrong
back but he also has a phonetic you
would have seen this kind of Ethernet
port on the Sun which Steve did a video
about video let's go to our desk so this
is the online debugging tool and from
here you can you can kind of check the
status of registers the most among them
to be empty you can then sir values into
memory and then you know go back and
check them so we just deposited for for
example in address 1000 in in octal and
we can go back and see that that's been
deposited so on earlier pdp-11 sweeney
bus machines you would have had to do
this with switches on the front much
like in the recent altair video yeah
let's type this this program and all
this program does is is allow you to
type and see the characters back on the
screen so normally if I if I do this it
kind of works but it's trying to do
something in no DT which is you know
causing an error so we'll type this
program in I'll probably make a mistake
and it'll take me a while to figure out
what I typed in wrong so ctrl J is the
line feed if you press character turn it
it stops and goes back into into normal
mode so this is one seven seven five six
zero then we have into put five seven
one zero okay I think I've entered the
program we can quickly check so
this one this one these are actually raw
assembly instructions expressed an octal
so you could turn these into binary and
see the move instructions for example
this top line here I can show you is
moving the address of the serial court
or the serial port into register 0 so it
knows where to to read and write from so
let's try and run this program
I think I have it in halt mode so I
think I have to go back to the machine
so now I can actually type words the bad
keyboard is just a carriage return so it
actually takes you back to the beginning
of the line there's no line feed I think
maybe I can present yeah I can press
ctrl 10 now we have a if you can I do
this to a are interviewed hover you know
very expensive type right very expensive
toy for I say today yeah so that's yeah
so obviously this is yeah my oh no no
okay so the whole key isn't self on here
so if I want to reset it and we can boot
into UNIX I have to go back over here
and condom and reset the machine it's
the early days of computing so you have
to do I'm loading UNIX off the scheduler
to SD card emulator I can press control
C here and it'll actually go into the
bootloader so you can see a bunch of
options for example they can boot off
Arlo Arlo won or ro 2 which is 5
megabytes in 10 megabytes respectively
or XO 2 is the half a megabyte floppy
disk that 8 inches wide the thing that
we're booting from is D u 0 which is
this MSC P which stands for the Mass
Storage control protocol and this came
later in pdp-11 his life and just really
simplified the process of booting into
an operating system so we run to D 0
here which is the scuzzy disk which
contains 2.11 bsd there was unix from
AT&T or Bell Labs and then there was a
fork of that from Berkeley which was
called BSD this version of BSD
is actually from the 90s it's kind of I
think it's taken like the networking
parts of a later BST and move them into
2.10 or something so this is 2.11 bsd is
slightly improved so this is the actual
UNIX bootloader once you get past the
pdp-11 bootloader and this is where it
starts to take some time it boots into
single user mode first so you don't have
to log in and you just automatically
root and then once it's booted into that
you can you can access it and it will
boot into multi-user mode and you know
people can tell it into your machine
actually wrote a web server for this
machine as well so when it's running at
home you can connect to it and see a
picture of it running it takes like
three seconds to load the page there's a
matter what speed you're in toys ah I
think we need to I haven't used it on
this phone or before there we go okay so
this is in single user mode we can do an
LS and you'll see the root of the
filesystem do things like this usage to
check the size so this is in one
kilobyte blocks I think it's very
similar to modern UNIX we can go into
the games folder
I think Sean's been wanting to have a
look at hawk there's no secret that
wouldn't doing a few films based around
ready player one one of the key plot
points in the book is about the game's
orc which I believe was developed on the
machine like this so yeah you have here
that this is a variant absorb which
seems to name various digital machines
like the pdp-11
in it for some reason so this is the
kind of format of zorka's it kind of
tells you where you are gives you a
description of your environment and you
have to enter some commands such as in
this case it says there's a small
mailbox here so we can try and open the
mailbox I haven't gotten very far
through this game so it says there's a
leaflet inside the mailbox so let's read
the leaflet and I think it's quite long
so you can pause it if you want to read
it but you see here is it mentioned the
deck system no deck system should be
with that one so I don't actually know
do you have any ideas how to continue
through this game the current version
was translated from MDL into fortune for
by a somewhat paranoid deck
engineer who prefers to remain anonymous
alright so let's try it helped because I
have no idea of what to do I think I can
pause like this but I think I've already
missed the most important stuff
can we go north or something I've heard
people do that you're facing the north
side of a white house there is no ball
here go east I don't know yeah at least
one corner of the house can we open the
window let's see if that it's great
effort you open the window far enough to
allow passage I do this alright we're in
the kitchen now that was easy Papa loose
here can I drink it one of the key
things about this game up in what I've
looked into was that it was a bit more
open to different commands maybe I don't
know how it does it I guess that was one
of the reasons why it was written in
Lisp originally it was commonly used at
that time for artificial intelligence
and natural language processing type
applications like this but yeah I don't
know how to get any further in this game
maybe we can just go north or something
but now there's a wall let's get in
there this could take some time
yeah I probably won't bother but what's
next for the machine then what's next
for the pdp-11 or what's notes for your
collection what's yes I'm I'm still
trying to get my my earlier two drives
which is you know this 10 megabyte
removable platter drive they don't work
they sort there getting there there's
definitely something wrong with them
still that's taking up my previous
weekend will probably take up the next
few weekends as well but yeah I just
want these things to work I think
they're interesting machines and this is
shame if they're just lying you know in
a skip broken or something like that
[Music]